rando pays vous propose cette semaine
une randonnée incontournable dans l'est
le tour du grand étang
rendez vous au parking du grand étang
notre accompagnateur du jour sera jean
marie poser du parc national
depuis le parking un sentier large et
empirer sert de marche d'approché sur un
premier petit kilomètre
tout y est
vous
un jour
quand on arrive au grand étang deux
possibilités s'offrent à nous pour en
faire le tour par la droite ou par la
gauche
nous choisissons le côté gauche
les habitués du site saurons ce que ça
signifie
très rapidement en effet le sentier
atteint une zone de falaise dans
laquelle quand le niveau de l'eau est
trop élevé le passage n'est plus
possible
/
un piège qu'il vaut mieux connaître pour
éviter cette mésaventure en vérifiant le
niveau d'eau au départ du sentier nous
sommes donc obligés de rebrousser chemin
le plus simple pour cette fois ci reste
donc de partir par la droite en aller
retour
le grand étang est une curiosité de
notre île contrairement aux étangs du
goal ou de saint paul en embouchure de
ravines et sur le littoral il se situe
en altitude à 500 mètres environ et les
raisons de sa formation sont plutôt
original
la petite histoire c'est qu'en fait via
les rivières donc les cascades du bras
d'un être qui s'écoulait qui donnait
lieu à une rivière
il ya plusieurs milliers d'années en
arrière il ya un petit volcan donc des
pythons qui se sont formés on peut voir
on peut voir juste en face de nous et
qui a obstrué l'écoulement de cette
rivière
la nature a ceinturé cet étang par un
relief donc qui s'est formé soit depuis
l'héritage du piton des neiges tous les
remparts qu'on a autour de seconde étant
c'est ce qu'on hérite un des coulées de
lave du piton des neiges
et puis manière plus récente c'est petit
piton qui se sont créées qui a fermé
qu'à fermer
l'écoulement de la rivière pour
constituer le grand étang encore le
grand étang est une randonnée parmi les
plus classiques c'est peut-être pour
cela que certains oiseaux habitué aux
fréquents passages sont peu farouches
comme ce chaque watt aux oiseaux la
vierge chez google
quand on arrive au bout de l'étang le
säntis peut continuer à faire le tour de
l'autre côté mais nous savons déjà que
cela n'est pas possible aujourd'hui on
peut surtout aussi remonté la rivière
sur 500 mètres en direction des cascades
et l'ambiance change radicalement
lorsqu'on se rapproche les cascades du
bras d'anne est donc de la paroisse qui
est tout au fond on est proche de la
ravine et des ensembles de cascades donc
ce qui crée une ambiance très humide et
à proximité on a des forêts qui sont
dans un meilleur état
donc cette humidité les arbres sont
recouverts de mousse d'orchidées et de
fougères et c'est extrêmement agréable
d'avoir cette fraîcheur et ce paysage
qui changent au fur et à mesure qu'on
parcourt ce sentier
m
enfin nous arrivons cascade du grade
annette et ses deux bassins
un lieu idéal et rafraîchissant pour
terminer notre randonnée
ce que j'aime sans donner déjà c'est que
lorsqu'on y arrive on allait sur une
aire de pique nique et aménagé après sur
le sentier ce qui est assez sympa c'est
que déjà c'est pas très compliqué il est
un petit peu vallonné mais donc c'est
pour tout public avec des enfants on
peut très bien y accéder et ils
découvrent avons un paysage qui est
extraordinaire cette pièce d'eau centre
avec les remparts de chaque côté donc ça
nous fait des paysages qui est
remarquable et surtout lorsqu'on arrive
vers la fin vers l'embouchure avec ses
cascades cette rivière
ça fait des ambiances qui sont vraiment
très différentes tout le long de ce
parcours et ça c'est extrêmement
plaisant mon côté aussi intérêt pour
ceux qui aiment plutôt le côté nature
naturaliste il ya plein de choses à
découvrir c'est vraiment un site qui est
remarquable fantastique très accessible
avec une superbe diversité c'est quand
même un peu moins c'est caractère un peu
boueux donc on est on se situe plein
l'est donc sur les entrées des alizés
donc c'est un site où il pleut en
moyenne 5 à 6 mètres d'eau par an donc
on est sur une zone très pluvieuse bon
on sait que zone pluvieuse et sentiers
dont il ya de la boue donc il faut avoir
conscience de ça lorsqu'on vient
parcourir ce sentier c'est que après les
fortes pluies
donc il faut pas avoir peur de se salir
un peu voilà donc ça reste possible d'y
accéder mais avec un peu de boue un peu
de glissade de temps en temps mais ça
reste très facilement franchissable tout
ça